[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: OK, why
don't we get started?
Since I had some problems
with the end of last lecture,
I'm going to pick up
right where things
got a little dicey
in the last lecture,
and we're going to start over.
So we're looking back at figure
7-3, which, if you remember,
was the cost curves for our cost
function 10 plus 5q squared.
And you remember
where it came from.
This cost function
we derived ourselves
from the production function
and wages and rental rates.
We derived this cost function.
We're now graphing the
cost curves that come out
of this cost function,
and we're talking
about profit maximization.
And we're talking
about measuring profit.
So we're talking about
perfect competition.
And remember, we
said that profits
are revenues minus costs.
That means the profits
per unit are revenues
per unit minus costs per unit.
Revenues per unit are price, and
cost per unit is average cost.
So profits per unit is price
minus the average cost.
So we just go to the diagram.
You see the height of
the profit rectangle
is price minus the average cost.
So what do you do?
You start by finding the point.
So what are your steps here?
Step one is you
find the point where
price equals marginal cost.
That gives you your
production level.
That gives your optimal q star--
we derived that last time--
of 3.
We derived that last time that
you want to optimize the price
equals marginal cost.
That gives our q star of 3.
Then at that level, we
compute the average cost.
Average cost at q
of 3 is simply going
to be this cost
function divided by 3--
so 10 over 3 plus 5q
squared over 3, or just 5q,
plus 15, OK?
So the average cost at
three is going to be $18.33.
That's going to be the average
cost at production of three.
That means that
the profits we're
making for that third unit,
the profits on our third unit,
is the price--
profits per unit are the price,
which is a fixed level of 30,
minus the average
cost, which is $18.33.
So profits per
unit equals $11.67.
So that's the profits.
That's the height
of the rectangle.
The profits per unit is $11.67.
The price minus the
average cost is $11.67.
We're selling three units, so
that means our total profit
rectangle is 35, OK?
So our total profits
are 35, which
is three units at a
profit of $11.67 each.
And that's how we
get that rectangle.
Questions about that?
OK.
So now, let's return to
what we did last time.
Let's imagine there's
a tax of $10 per unit.
That would shift the
cost curve to C equals 10
plus 5q squared plus 10q.
Remember, it's a tax
per unit, plus 10q.
That would mean-- so that is
illustrated in figure 7-4.
That means that the marginal
cost curve and the average cost
curve both shift up.
Marginal cost is now
equal to 10q plus 10.
We want to set that equal to
the price to get the optimal q,
and you solve this and you
get a new q star equals 2.
So now your optimal
production level is two.
You set your new marginal
cost equal to the price.
Marginal cost equals price.
Marginal cost equals price at
a new optimal quantity of two.
What's the profits there?
Well, once again,
profits per unit
are just price, which is
$30, minus average cost.
Well, what's the
average cost at two?
The average cost at two
is going to be 10 over q--
so 5.
10 over 2 is 5, OK?
Plus 5q because we're dividing
this by q, 5q, which is 10, OK?
Plus 10, OK?
30 minus 25, which equals 5.
So your profits per unit,
the height of that rectangle,
has fallen from $11.67 to $5.
So you're now making
less profit per unit
and you're selling fewer units.
The height of the
rectangle has shrunk.
The width of the
So the total profits have
fallen from $30 to $10.
You used to make profits of
$11.67 on each of three units.
Now you make profits of
$5 on each of two units.
So that tax has lowered your
profits from $30 to $10, OK?
Question about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that by changing
the cost [INAUDIBLE]??
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yes, exactly.
Because you have a higher cost--
now, it's not just
that your costs change.
Your costs changing fed through
to your production as well.
So because your
costs change, you
produce at a different
level and you made
different profit per unit, OK?
All right.
Now, let's go to
the other point I
tried to cover last time that
I want to get straight on,
which is the shutdown decision.
Now remember, we are, in
the short run, shut down.
We're in the short run.
In the short run, there's
no entry and exit.
The firm can't literally leave,
but it can just produce zero.
That we call the short-run
shutdown decision.
A short-run shutdown decision,
you're still in the market.
You still paid your fixed costs.
You just produce zero.
That's what we mean by
shutdown, as opposed to exit,
which is literally you
take your toys and leave.
This is you're
still in the market.
You've paid your fixed costs.
You can't go
anywhere-- remember,
those costs are fixed
in the short run--
but you just produce zero.
So now let's ask,
for example, what
happens if the price
suddenly dropped to $10.
Let's say the price
dropped from $30 to $10.
Well, the fundamental
profit-maximization rule
never changes.
We're not having
the tax anymore.
We're back to the
original cost function.
So original cost function is C
equals 10 plus 5q squared, OK?
So the marginal
cost equals 10q, and
our profit-maximization
rule does not change.
Our profit-maximization
rule is that price
equals marginal cost.
So we set 10q to 10,
marginal cost equal to price.
$10 is the price.
And we get that the optimal
quantity is now one.
We now want to produce one unit.
That's the optimal quantity.
Well, what is our profits
if we produce one unit?
Well, profits equals
revenues, $10, minus costs.
Well, what's our cost
if we produce one unit?
10 plus 5, 15.
So profits are negative 5.
I'm going fast, so jump in if
I get the math wrong here, OK?
Profits are negative 5.
So you might think that's
terrible, using money.
You should get out
of there, shut down.
But the answer is, as
we discussed last time,
you should not shut down
because shutting down still
means paying your fixed costs.
No matter what you do, you
have to pay those fixed costs.
So shutting down means
production of zero.
What are your profits
at a production of zero?
Your profits at a
production of zero
are zero revenues minus
the fixed cost of $10.
If you produce zero,
what's your cost?
Plug 0 in here.
Your costs are still 10.
So if you produce zero,
your profits are minus 10.
So you should
continue to sell even
though you're losing money.
Even though you're
losing money, you
continue to sell that one unit.
You don't go to zero.
Because at zero,
you're even worse off.
This is the key thing about
short-run shutdown decision.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What happens if you're
in a position where, like, you
are afraid you're going
to keep selling one
unit the next couple of months?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Ah, but
that's the key thing.
Once you move to the long run,
you can reoptimize your capital
and you can exit.
But in the short run,
you've already paid that.
You've already laid down your
blanket, which cost you $10.
You might as well
sell at a loss.
If you just sell
zero, then you've
laid down your blanket for $10
and gotten nothing out of it,
OK?
That's the transition
to the long run.
And so basically, that's how
you think about the short run
versus the long run.
So what do we think
about how this works?
So basically, the
shutdown rule, the way
you think of the math
of the shutdown rule
is that basically you
only want to shut down
if your revenues are less
than your variable costs
because you got to pay your
fixed cost no matter what.
That's done.
You're in the short run.
That's gone.
Forget it.
You laid your blanket
down in the bazaar.
That's done.
So you only want to shut
down if your revenues are
less than your variable costs.
You don't care about
your fixed costs.
That's done.
You only shut down
if your revenues are
less than your variable costs.
Well, that's the same
as saying you only want
to shut down if your price--
variable costs are pq--
I'm sorry, your variable cost.
You only shut down
if your price are
less than your average
variable cost--
so divide by q.
You only shut down
if your price is
less than your average
variable costs.
That's the shutdown rule.
Shut down if the
price you get is less
than, on average, what
you'll get unit for the units
you sell.
So in our example,
you never shut down.
And why is that?
Let's look at the
math of our example.
Well, in our example,
what are variable costs?
The variable cost is 5q squared.
I'm going to put these down
here so I don't have to--
the variable costs in our
example, variable costs
are 5q squared.
So what are average
variable costs?
5q.
Those are average
variable costs.
Now, remember that you want to
shut down if variable costs are
greater than the price.
We can express the
price in terms of q.
Because remember, marginal
cost equals price.
So 10q equals p.
So at the optimum, it is always
true that p equals q over 10.
That's a profit-maximizing
condition,
that p equals q over 10.
We can just substitute
that in, and we
have that average variable
costs equals 5 times q.
So average variable costs equals
0.5 times p at the optimum.
Because we know that the optimum
marginal cost equals price,
we can plug that in and say,
at the optimum, average cost
is 0.5 times p.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you mean
q equals p over 10?
JONATHAN GRUBER: q-- let
me see if I got that wrong.
Yes, I'm sorry.
q equals p over 10.
You're right.
q equals p over 10, my bad.
Sorry.
So the average variable
cost is 0.5 times p.
What's the shutdown rule?
The shutdown rule is
that price is less
than average variable cost or
price is less than 0.5 price,
which can never be true.
So you'd never shut down
with this cost function.
To say it again,
you only shut down
if price is less than
average variable cost.
We've computed average variable
cost in terms of price,
and it's 0.5 times price.
Therefore, you never shut down.
And you could see this
when we actually go to--
so you can actually
see this in figure 7-5
when we look at the
firm's supply decision.
So what figure 7-5
does is show you,
at every price,
what the firm wants
to produce in the short run.
At a price of $10, it
wants to produce one.
We showed you that.
At a price of $20, it
wants to produce two.
At a price of $30, it wants
to produce three, and so on.
That dash-- that line that runs
from 0, 0 all the way up to 4,
40, that's the
marginal cost line.
At each point, price
equals marginal cost,
the optimal production decision.
And you never shut down.
As long as price is
positive, you produce.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in this case, we
don't set price to 10 minus p?
Because if it's 10,
then [INAUDIBLE]
will be higher than 10.
JONATHAN GRUBER: I'm sorry.
I don't understand.
AUDIENCE: So--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Price is always
above average variable cost,
so you'd never shut down, right?
That's the shutdown rule.
This can never be true
with this function.
Price is forever above
average variable cost.
You can see that in
this graph, right?
The price equals
the marginal cost,
and that is always above the
average variable cost, OK?
So the bottom line is
you'd never shut down.
But here's the other cool thing.
After all this confusing
math, guess what this line
is, this marginal cost line.
What else do we call that?
That's the supply curve, people.
We just derived
the supply curve.
What's the supply curve?
The supply curve
is the relationship
between the price in the
market and the amount
the producer desires to produce.
Well, that's what this
marginal cost curve is.
So we've just shown you that the
firm's supply curve is simply
its marginal cost curve.
So all you need to know to
derive what a firm's supply
curve looks like is what its
marginal cost curve looks like,
and you're done.
So literally, you take
production plus input prices,
and that gives you
the supply curve.
Why?
Because production
plus input prices
gives you the cost function.
Take the derivative of the
cost function with respect
to quantity.
That gives you the
marginal cost function.
That's the supply curve.
So just like I could give you
a utility function and a budget
constraint and you got
the demand curve, here, I
can give you a production
function and input prices
and it gets the supply curve--
however, only under
perfect competition, OK?
This is only for the case
of perfect competition.
That's different
from consumer theory.
That was an everywhere rule.
Because I've given you an
extra constraint, which
is a constraint on
the market, I've
allowed you to derive the
supply curve just like we easily
derived the demand curve.
So we have now derived
a firm's supply curve.
Questions about that?
So let's go back one more time.
Just like if I give you on,
say, a problem set or an exam
a utility function and
a budget constraint,
you should be able to
draw a demand curve.
If I give you a production
function and input prices
and I tell you you're
in perfect competition,
then you should be able
to draw a supply curve
because it's just the
marginal cost curve, OK?
Now, that's the
firm's supply curve.
What we care about,
actually, in the end,
is the market
supply curve, right?
I've been doing little q.
We care about big Q. That's
what I drew in the lecture,
was a big Q diagram.
So how do we get there?
Well, all you do to
get the market supply
is to horizontally sum
each firm's supply.
So we can see that
in figure 7-7, OK?
What figure 7-7 does is take
multiple identical firms
and put them in the market.
So for example, if there's
one firm in the market,
the supply curve is
what we just drew.
At a price of $10, you get 10.
At a price of $10, you get one.
At a price of $30,
you get three.
Now let's add a
second identical firm.
Well, that firm
behaves the same way.
At a price of $10,
it produces one.
And at a price of $30,
it produces three.
So the market now suddenly
has twice as much.
At a price of $10, it has two.
At a price of $30, it has six.
Now let's add a third firm.
It behaves the same way.
At a price of $10,
it produces one.
At a price of $3,
it produces three.
So each additional firm
you add just literally
shifts the supply curve down.
So in other words, the point
is that a market supply curve,
as you add more and more
firms, the market supply curve
is always more elastic
than the firm's supply
curve because any
given increase in price
calls for, from each firm,
an increase in quantity.
As long as there's
multiple firms,
that means a flatter
market supply curve
than a firm's supply curve.
So that's how we get
the market supply curve.
We solve for the
firm's supply curve.
We then just horizontally
sum it over the number
of firms in the market.
Get the firm supply curve,
horizontally sum, OK?
Questions about that?
Now, now we have
everything we need
to go back to the first
lecture, back to the future,
back to the first lecture.
And we can actually get
to market equilibrium.
In the first lecture,
we started with a supply
curve and a demand curve
and got equilibrium.
Well, we derived the demand
curve a few lectures ago.
We've just derived
the supply curve.
So let's do short-run
equilibrium.
Let's do short-run
equilibrium, OK?
Now, the key thing is that--
so how do we do
short-run equilibrium?
Let's go through the steps.
Step one, each firm picks
a fixed amount of capital
it's going to have
in the short run.
So each firm has a K bar.
And based on that, it has
a production function.
Each firm has a
production function,
q equals f of k, K bar, L.
And we have some input prices.
We have some w and some r.
Taken together, we can use
those to create a cost function,
which, in our example,
was C equals 10
plus 5q squared, step one.
Step two.
Step two, based on this, we can
get optimal production levels
from the fundamental
profit-maximization rule,
MC equals p.
So this yields-- so here,
we say 10q equals p.
And this yields
a supply function
which is q equals p over 10,
and that's our supply curve.
That's what I drew
here. q equals p over 10
is the firm's supply curve.
That's step two.
Step three is to create
a market supply curve.
Well, let's say there's
six firms in the market.
I'm just pulling
this out of thin air.
In a minute, we'll get to
how many firms there are.
But for now, in the short run,
there's no entry and exit.
So whatever number of firms I
tell you, that's what's there.
It's just given.
So let's say n equals 6.
Let's say there's six firms.
And I'll come in a minute
to where six comes from.
But for now, let's
just assume it.
That means that the total
market supply, big Q,
is just equal to 6 little
q, 6 little q, which
equals 3/5 p or 6/10 p.
That is our market supply curve.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Would
firms that change
[INAUDIBLE] who are out there?
Would that change the overall--
JONATHAN GRUBER: The number
of firms that are out there?
Yeah, but once again, once
they're in, they're done.
They know there's six firms.
So they're done.
I'm going to come to this.
You're talking about
the long run, OK?
Other questions?
Yeah-- OK.
So that gives you
your market supply.
Finally, we go back to lecture
one and the first recitation
where you solved
mathematically for equilibrium.
We have a demand curve.
I'm just going to make this up.
Let's say the demand curve
is Q equals 40 minus p.
I just made that up
to make the math easy.
Where does this come from?
Well, you know where
that comes from.
You solved where
That comes from consumer
maximization, 48 minus p.
So to get equilibrium,
we just set
48 minus p equal to 3/5
p, demand equal to supply.
And we end up with p equals 30,
conveniently familiar number,
which means that the
total demand, big Q,
is 48 minus 30 equals 18,
also convenient number.
And I'll show you why.
The fifth step, each firm
says, given this price,
what do I want to produce?
Well, we know that
given a price of 30,
each firm's little
q star is 3, right?
That's what we solved.
Each firm's little q star
is 3 given a price of 30.
So each firm
produces three units.
How many firms are there?
AUDIENCE: Six.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
What's 6 times 3?
Supply equals demand.
Six firms produce three
each at a price of 30.
That's 18.
At a price of 30, people
want 18, equilibrium.
That's how it all works.
So leaving aside where
the six came from,
everything else you see here
is just taking what we did
and working out the math.
And we get six
firms in the market.
They each want to produce three.
That's the 18 that people want.
So to get equilibrium,
you just need--
to get equilibrium, you
need a demand curve,
you need a cost function,
and you need the number
of firms in the market.
You need a demand curve.
You need the cost
function and the number
of firms in the market.
Given that, you can solve
for the equilibrium.
Questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So thinking
about this in terms
of the intersection
of the graphs,
would intersecting the demand
curve with the whole market's
supply curve--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah, because
it's the whole market demand
curve.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Q equals 48 minus
p is the demand curve.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Q equals 48
minus p is the demand curve.
Other questions?
Good questions.
Those are good,
clarifying questions.
OK, so now let's ask where
the hell six comes from.
And where six comes
from is the fact--
where six comes from
is from the long run.
So now we get to
long-run competition,
which is, in the
short run, there's
a certain number of
firms in the market.
But where those firms come from?
Well, they come from the
fact that each short run
is a repeated exercise
that makes up the long run.
So in the long run, perfect
competition in the long run
looks just like perfect
competition in the short run--
full information, no
transaction cost, lots of firms,
with one difference.
We're now going to
allow entry and exit.
Nothing else is going to
change in the short run
except we're now going
to allow entry and exit.
So now, what-- and
one other thing.
I'm sorry.
One other thing changes.
Since all costs are variable,
there's no shutdown decision.
There's no issue of
this shutdown rule.
There's no more fixed costs.
So if you lose money, in
the long run, you shut down.
So all you have to
worry about is profits.
You don't have to worry
about this extra shut--
so in the short run, we had
an extra shutdown condition.
You don't worry about
that in the long run.
You just worry about if you're
making money or losing money.
In the long run, if you're
making money, you're in.
If you're losing
money, you're out.
So now let's ask
how that pins down
the number of firms
in the market.
This is complicated, so the
best way to do it, I think,
is an example.
And think about our--
the fundamental rule
I want you to keep
in mind-- and the example
gives you this rule.
The simple rule is if there's
profits to be made, you enter.
If there's losses, you exit.
And these two things together
imply the fundamental rule
of competitive equilibrium--
that in the long run,
profits are zero.
Because if there's ever
profit in the market,
firms will come in.
And if there's ever loss in
the market, firms will exit.
And that process will continue
until profits are zero.
So our fundamental conclusion
is the long-run competitive
equilibrium features
zero profits.
Now let's see why.
Let's go to figure 8-1.
I want to talk about the
market for personal computers.
Let's see.
You guys were born what year?
So you're now, like, 18.
So you're born, like, 1990.
This is about when
you guys are born, OK?
1990 was a very interesting
time for PC market.
You all grew up in a PC world,
a personal computer world.
But basically, in 1990, we're
in a very different world.
We're in a world that was
dominated by giant mainframe
computers.
My graduation speaker
from MIT in 1987
was Ken Olsen, the
chairman of DEC,
which was one of the
premier manufacturer
of giant computers.
He gave the worst
fucking graduation speech
you've ever seen.
If you ever become famous
and give a graduation speech,
the number one rule is
don't spend the whole speech
talking about yourself.
He spent the whole speech
talking about how wonderful he
was, how DEC was everything.
And five years later,
he was bankrupt.
So take that, Ken Olsen.
That's why you don't
give a speech talking
about how wonderful you are.
What happened?
Well, let's talk
about what happened.
Let's talk about
the PC market, OK?
I hope Ken Olsen
doesn't watch this.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's talk about the PC market.
Let's talk about Dell, who
was an early PC manufacturer.
And what we're going
to do in figure 8-1,
there's going to be two
side-by-side graphs.
I'm going to go back
and forth between them.
If you're ever not clear about
which graph I'm talking about,
stop me.
But I'll try to be
very clear because you
have to think about both
these graphs in tandem.
On the right-hand
side is the market
for PCs, the market graph.
On the left-hand side
is Dell's cost curves.
So the left-hand side graph is
firm-specific Dell information.
The right-hand side
graph is the market.
In the short run, we
were at a position
where people wanted
PCs, and there weren't
many people making them.
You guys, PCs were super cool.
I mean, I guess, you're on
laptops and everything now.
But a desktop PC was an
amazing thing at this point.
Everyone wanted them,
and there weren't
that many people making them.
So at that point, Dell could--
the short-run market
cost curve was SR1,
and the demand was D.
That was the short--
so we're starting on the right.
We're going to go from
the right to the left.
Start in the right.
The initial market in 1990
was the short-run cost curve
SR1 and the demand curve of D.
At that intersection,
the price was p1.
Meanwhile, Dell,
in the short run,
had a marginal cost curve such--
now shift to the
left-hand diagram.
At a price of p1, Dell wants
to produce little q1 PCs--
marginal cost
equals price, right?
So find the intersection of that
price with its marginal cost
curve.
Once again, this
is very important.
So stop me if I'm
going too fast.
Find where the price
intersects the marginal cost
curve on the left.
Dell wants to produce little q1.
Well, what's its profits?
Profits are price
minus average cost.
Well, its average cost
was way below that.
So Dell made this huge profit
of the lightly shaded rectangle.
That was its profit because
it produced little q1.
At little q1, average
cost was way below price.
So it made this lighted
dot rectangle on profits.
Now what happens?
Other companies see this
and say, hey, we want in.
What happens as more
companies enter a market?
The supply curve flattens.
You're horizontally
summing firm supply curve.
Supply curve flattens.
As it flattens, you
move from SR1 to SR2.
So now we're back on the right.
In the market, as
more firms enter--
and let's assume there are
more firms identical to Dell.
That's our perfect
competition assumption,
that each firm that enters
is sort of identical.
So more firms just
like Dell enter.
Gateway and all these
guys start entering.
And you shift to
SR2, a flatter curve.
That intersects the demand
curve at the new price p2.
Now shift to the
left-hand diagram.
The price facing
Dell falls to p2,
but their cost function
hasn't changed.
They're still Dell.
They're still the same
underlying technology,
paying the same wages
and rental rates.
So now, their marginal
cost curve is the same.
So at this new lower
price, their production
drops to little q2.
Their production
drops to little q2
and their profits fall to the
darkly shaded rectangle, pi 2.
They make less money
as firms enter.
And this process will continue
until profits go to zero.
Even at pi 2, another firm--
I forget what the
third PC firm was.
Some other firm will come
in and say, wait a second.
There's still money to be made.
I want to come in.
And it'll keep going
till profits go to zero.
These are repeated short runs.
So SR1 was a short run.
Dell made a ton of money.
Then we get to the
next short run.
Gateway enters.
SR2's the new short run.
Gateway and Dell
still make money.
So the third period, another
firm's going to enter.
And it's going to go
till profits equal zero.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this assume
that the manufacturers or all
the different companies produce
the same amount of quantity
and that they're the
same quality, right?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Yes, absolutely.
I'm going to come to those--
there's a large set of
assumptions under this.
But once again, think
of Dell and Gateway
selling their computers on rugs
in front of the Eiffel Tower.
It's all the same.
You just go.
You can compare equally.
They're all the same thing.
So it's that kind of market, OK?
Now let's think
about poor, old IBM.
Flip the page.
IBM dominated-- despite
Ken Olsen's claims,
IBM dominated the
big computer market.
And so they were initially,
on the right-hand side,
in equilibrium with
supply curve SR1.
That intersected demand-- now
we're on the mainframe market.
So in figure 8-1,
we're in the PC market.
Figure 8-1 is the PC market.
Figure 8-2 is the
mainframe market.
The mainframe market,
they're initially
at supply curve one, which is
very flat because there's lots
of firms making mainframes.
It intersects demand
at a price p1, OK?
Now we go to the left.
Well, remember, IBM
has to produce where
its marginal cost equals price.
That occurs at
production level q1.
At production level of
q1, it is losing money.
IBM is losing money.
It is losing that
entire rectangle,
the entire large rectangle.
Now, does IBM exit?
It can't in the short
run, but in the long run,
the next period,
some firms will exit.
Some firms will say, yeah, we
lost money in the short run.
We're stuck.
But in the long
run, we just don't
think this is a winning game.
In particular, firms with
high fixed costs will exit.
They don't want to pay
those fixed costs again
in the second period.
They know they have to
build a new factory.
They're not going to do it.
They exit.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What
constitutes as a period?
I know we said the
long run is when--
JONATHAN GRUBER: I told
you I can't tell you that.
It's just some period of
time more than a month,
less than 10 years, OK?
It's the period over
which capital is variable.
Think of it as a period
of time over which you can
build a new plant to make PCs.
Think of it that way.
So it's years, OK?
So what happens, then, somebody
exits, says, I'm out of this.
I'm shutting down the plant
and moving somewhere else.
That's steepens the market
supply curve because now fewer
firms are in the market.
As that steepens
the supply curve,
the new intersection
of supply and demand
is at the higher price p2.
IBM stayed in the market.
They just built a new plant.
At p2, they now
produce an amount q2.
And at that combination, they
are literally zero profit.
That's the point where marginal
cost equals average cost, which
is a zero-profit point.
Why is that zero profits?
It's zero profits
because, remember,
profits are price
minus average cost.
What's price?
Marginal cost.
So when marginal cost equals
average cost, profits are zero.
You should be able to see that
from the math we did before.
So what that means
is that basically,
when firms are losing
money, they will leave
and drive profits from
below zero toward zero.
So when they're
making money, they
enter and drive profits from
above zero towards zero.
When they're losing money,
they leave and drive
profits from below
zero towards zero.
What does that mean?
That means that our long-run
perfectly competitive supply
curve is in figure 8-3.
It's flat.
Long-run perfectly
competitive market supply
is flat at the price level.
The market long-run
supply is the point
where marginal cost
equals average cost
or where supply equals
average cost, OK?
And why is this?
This is true because at
any price above that point,
if any firm tries to
charge more than $10,
they'll be driven
out of business.
If any firm tries
to charge below $10,
they won't make any money.
Remember before,
I said earlier--
you said, well, gee why
don't firms just-- somebody
asked, why don't firms just come
in and take the whole market?
This is why.
Because cost is upward sloping.
You don't want to come
and take the whole market.
You'll lose money.
That's why firms don't
want the whole market.
If marginal cost was flat, then
you would then be undefined.
You would want the whole market.
But you don't.
Marginal cost is rising.
So you never want to
produce at a price above $10
because no one
will buy from you.
You never want to
set a price below $10
because you'll lose money.
Therefore, supply is perfectly
elastic at a price of $10.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thinking about
this long-run logic
then, wouldn't [INAUDIBLE]?
JONATHAN GRUBER: No, no, no.
Once again, there's a lot
of assumptions under this.
But under these
assumptions, you never
make money in the long run
because they shut down.
There are short-run periods.
So let's say what happened was--
let's go back to figure 8-2.
Let's say that another firm
shut down in the next period
and suddenly IBM
started making money.
What would happen?
Someone would enter and
drive profits back to zero.
So under the assumptions
we've laid out here,
profits are zero.
Because in the long run, we've
achieved cost minimization.
Firms minimize their
costs where marginal cost
equals average cost.
Look at the average cost curve.
Firms are producing
at the minimum.
The minimum of average
cost is where average cost
equals marginal cost.
That is, competition has
forced cost minimization.
I'm just doing all sorts
of mind-blowing stuff
here for you guys.
It can take hours to
recover from this.
Competition forces
cost minimization.
Why?
Because competition
forces each firm
to produce where price
equals marginal cost,
and it forces entry and
exit until marginal cost
equals average cost.
Therefore, it forces
each firm to produce
at the most efficient
point, which
is where marginal cost
equals average cost,
because that is
the point at where
average cost is minimized.
So under competition,
in the long run,
every firm is cost-minimizing.
They're producing the minimum
of their average costs.
And therefore, the
supply curve is elastic,
and it's defined purely by
the minimum of average costs.
That is, if you know--
here's a cheat.
If you know you're in a
perfectly competitive market
and I give you a cost
function, then you know--
I guess you still need
the demand function too.
If I give a cost function
and a demand function,
you know you don't need
to know how many firms
are going to be in the market.
You don't need to know little n.
You know, in the long run,
profits are going to be zero.
So long run, firms
are just going
to produce at the
minimum of average cost.
You find that, use the
demand to find the price,
and you're done, OK?
So competition leads
to cost minimization.
Questions about that?
OK.
Now, you're all thinking,
well, wait a second.
We've got rich
parents, many of us who
make money in these businesses.
I don't see zero profits.
There's a stock market
that's been booming.
Where's the zero profits, buddy?
I don't see zero profits.
Well, the answer is twofold.
First of all, remember,
firms can make money
in the short run in this model.
But that doesn't explain
the stock market.
The stock market's supposed
to be forward-looking-- not
months, but years and decades.
So firms-- really,
long run profit's zero.
Why would stocks be expensive?
Why would people want to
invest in these companies?
And the answer is because these
assumptions are unrealistic--
that this is an extreme
version of the model that
delivers some nice
intuition, but doesn't
apply to the real world.
So I want to take
the last few minutes
to talk about the
assumptions that we've
made that don't really
work in the real world
to make this model work.
It doesn't mean the
model's invalid.
We learn a huge amount.
And the key lesson
from this model
is competition pushes you
towards cost minimization.
Always think about these models
as not delivering a level
truth, but a directional truth.
The directional lesson is this
is why competition forces firms
towards cost minimization,
but firms won't actually
necessarily get to zero profits.
And there's at least
three complications.
The first one is limited entry.
I assumed that firms could
costlessly enter and exit
in this market.
But in fact, that might be
hard because, in reality, we
have sunk costs, which I
talked about last time.
We have sunk costs--
or two times ago--
costs which, once paid,
can never be recovered.
And therefore, firms
might say, look,
I don't want to get
into this market
because it's not like I
can get my fixed cost back
out next period.
So if my fixed costs
are building a building,
next period, I can just sell
that building to someone else.
But my fixed costs are
going to med school.
I can't sell that
med school degree.
Therefore, if doctors aren't
going to be profitable
in the long run-- there'll be
zero profit in the long run--
I'm going to go be
a lawyer instead.
There are sunk costs,
and those sunk costs
create what we call
barriers to entry.
There are barriers to
entry that come from costs
that are sunk in the long run--
med schools.
But there are other sorts
of barriers to entry.
Take our vendor market.
Even in vendor markets,
they're not perfectly elastic.
One barrier to
entry could be they
could come in the middle of
the night and steal your stuff
and beat you up if you
tried to enter the market.
There's lots of reasons
why entry and exit is not
costless and easy.
There's lots of
barriers to entry.
Once there's a barrier to
entry, this graph goes away.
Because go back to figure 8-1.
In the second
short-run equilibrium,
we've got these small
profits, this small, dark gray
rectangle, right?
I then told you another firm
would enter and squeeze those
away, but another firm
will enter only if what?
Only under what-- somebody
raise their hand and tell me.
Under what condition would
that third firm enter?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Profits are
greater than zero.
JONATHAN GRUBER: No, not
profits are greater than zero.
In the model, that was true.
But in reality,
what has to be true?
Profits have to be
greater than what?
AUDIENCE: Sunk cost.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Sunk costs.
Raise your hand, people.
I'm going to give you
credit because you
raised your hand regardless
of who yelled out the answer.
I'll assume you were right.
Sunk costs.
Profits have to be greater
than the barriers to entry.
So in the short run,
you enter if profits
are greater than zero.
In the long run, you
only enter if profits
are greater than the barriers to
entry, which might not be true.
There's always some
cost to starting a firm.
So profits will never
really go to zero.
They'll only go down to
the barriers to entry.
So that's problem one.
Problem two with this
model, problem two
is firms may differ.
I've assumed-- and this
was raised in one question.
I've assumed
identical firms here.
But in fact, firms differ.
And in particular,
different firms
have different cost functions.
And with different
cost functions,
you can get some firms
making long-run profits.
So for example, let's
consider, in figure 8-4,
the long-run market
supply for cotton.
This is from a textbook example.
And this is from
estimates that people
have made of the minimum
average cost of producing cotton
by country.
So in other words, this is old
now, but it doesn't matter.
The country names don't matter.
The example's what matters.
In the period of time
this study was done,
the cheapest place to
produce cotton was Pakistan.
You produce cotton in
Pakistan for $0.71 per--
I don't know-- kilogram,
$0.71 per kilogram, OK?
However, that was only
for a certain amount.
At some point, Pakistan
ran out of cheap cotton
and they had to start
producing cotton using
more expensive methods.
Remember, marginal cost, at
some point, has to slope up.
So the point is
marginal cost was flat
for a while in Pakistan,
then has to slope up.
And suddenly, it becomes cheaper
to produce cotton in Argentina
at $1.08.
And then it becomes cheaper
to produce cotton in Australia
at $1.15.
And eventually, if the
price gets to $1.56,
it's finally cheap
enough to produce cotton
in the United States.
The point is these
flat segments represent
the minimum average
cost in each country.
It's just, instead
of making it a point,
there's an amount of
production they can do
with that minimum average cost.
Now, let's say world
demand for cotton
was 1 billion
kilograms per year.
Then what would happen
would be what I taught.
You would have Pakistan--
competitors in Pakistan would
compete, driving profits down
to zero.
And price would be
$0.71 per kilogram.
Now let's say, however,
demand for cotton
is 5 billion kilograms per year.
Well, now, that intersects
this supply curve.
This is the world supply curve.
There's the supply
curve at $1.71.
So now, US producers
are making zero profits
because their
marginal cost's $1.71.
The price is $1.71.
But what about
producers in Pakistan?
They still make cotton.
They make the first
almost 2 billion kilos.
But they're selling at $1.71,
and it's costing them $0.71.
So they just made profits.
The point is that if there are
firms which have rising costs
and demand is high enough
that the high-cost firms are
actually producing,
that higher price means
profits for the low-cost firm.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Would this increase
the price variable in Pakistan?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
You could imagine
those profits could
then have a feedback
effect in asset markets.
And you could imagine the long
run, in the very, very, very
long run, as people
buy land, that
could dissipate the profits.
That's a good point.
We'll come back to that.
But no, that's
very long run, OK?
But for now, people have
their land in Pakistan,
and they're making
their money on it.
And so that becomes
long-run profits.
So long-run profits can come
from heterogeneous costs.
If some firms are
particularly efficient
in a multimarket firm,
those firms can make money.
That's a second feature.
Now, the third feature
is, in some sense,
the most interesting, which is
input prices may not be fixed.
And in fact, input
prices, input prices--
ah.
Input may have an
upward-sloping supply.
There could be an upward-sloping
supply for inputs.
We've assumed input prices
are, everywhere, fixed,
but that's not true.
And in a few lectures, we'll
come and teach you about that.
But for now, let's
recognize that inputs may
have an upward-sloping supply.
So let's go through that for a
couple minutes before we stop.
Let's take a market
in figure 8-5.
This is the market for labor.
Now, we've only been
doing markets for goods
so far in this course, and
I'm sort of shortcutting
by jumping to here.
We'll spend a lot more
time on this graph.
But the bottom line is this is
a graph of the amount of labor
supply to the market.
In this graph, people
are now the suppliers
because they're supplying labor.
Firms are the demanders.
They're demanding labor.
So what happens is you
have supply curve of labor,
and let's assume
it's upward sloping.
What I mean by that is
as the wage goes up,
people want to work harder.
You want to work harder
as the wage goes up.
So it's an
upward-sloping supply.
It makes sense, right?
Upward-sloping supply of labor.
Now let's imagine a firm
suddenly wants to produce more.
They used to produce little q1.
Now they want to
produce little q2.
To do so, they
need more workers.
That represents a shift out
in the demand for workers.
With upward-sloping
supply, what does that do?
Raises the wage.
If you want more workers,
you've got to pay them more.
We didn't do that before.
We assumed W was a constant.
But imagine if, to produce
more, you have to pay more.
What does that do?
Well, you see that
in figure 8-6.
Now, I used to produce--
the market equilibrium used
to be at point E1 with n1
firms producing little q1.
So that point big E1--
biggie, big comma E1--
is little n1.
There was n firms producing
little q1 units per firm.
And they were making
these profits.
Their profits were where
price equaled marginal cost 1,
now shifting to the left.
p equals marginal
cost one at little e1.
So they were producing
where marginal cost equaled
average cost.
So little q1 at price
p1 meant that firms
producing at little e1, which
was the zero-profit point, OK?
Now what happens?
Now the firm wants
to produce more.
Demand goes up.
Firm wants to produce more.
It wants to produce q2.
You have a new long-run
equilibrium with n2 firms
producing q2.
Well, in that case, now
if you want to produce q2,
you're going to have
to pay a higher wage.
A higher wage means a higher
marginal average cost.
Higher marginal
average cost means
that you're now producing
at a higher price
and, therefore, the supply
curve slopes upward.
Now, this is very different.
One thing to think about--
I'll let you go.
One last thing to think,
think about the difference
between this third case
and the other two cases.
In the other two cases,
firms made profits.
In this case, firms
still don't make profits.
So notice that
profit's still zero,
but the supply curve's
upward sloping.
So you don't need
positive profits have
an upward-sloping supply curve.
So let's stop there.
I've given you a
lot to think about.
And we will come
back and talk more
about this stuff on Wednesday.